hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and
today I'm finally watching The Big
Lebowski
I've definitely lied about the zone
before he doesn't really do it for me
I think he was great as the dude um I
would get embarrassed and everyone would
be talking about these things and I
would say yeah oh not yeah for sure I
seen it I went to Edinburgh the end of
2016 I have a vlog about it on my
personal channel and I'm pretty sure
there's footage in that vlog of me going
to a Big Lebowski themed White Russian
bar this is a Big Lebowski themed bar
very decided and I the whole time just
was lying through my teeth just like Oh
get the was the funny part I love that
quote
looking back on footage and thinking
back on that and like I should one have
just watched the movie to be clear from
the get-go and to shouldn't have lied
about it I also in the past have
confused Jeff Bridges with Kurt Russell
I said that I wasn't a huge fan of
Caressa Lynn the thing reaction video
and that's because I was getting Kurt
Russell and Jeff Bridges confused and
then I saw Jeff Bridges and I'm linking
on it the hotel one I was never so happy
to be so wrong while watching a movie he
was so good in this aruba you guys
anyways I'm very excited to jump in and
right before we do all I want to say is
endgame spoiler no context okay
[Music]
that wouldn't be freakin rules I always
imagined to the dude to just be of this
like this burnt-out stoner guy which is
what he is but it's not like unbearable
sometimes it's super obnoxious I think
to watch stoner characters and my my my
uh how wrong was I he was so flippin
good the whole cast especially the three
bowlers were just out of this world I
mean John Goodman's best character of
all time yeah yeah yeah yeah Walter yeah
we've got this Sam Elliott narration
happening and there's music and there's
bowling and there's Steve Buscemi and
it's just every single conversation that
the three friends have is so
well-written and just super effortlessly
acted probably not effortlessly but it
looks effortless and it's so engaging
like him talking about the pee on the
rug and whose fault it is is just so
good they figure that it's this rich guy
named Lebowski and not the dude
obviously but these people breaking in
want the money from so the dude goes and
meets the Big Lebowski and that's when
you get holy Philip Seymour Hoffman who
was so good in this so subtle and
hilarious and perfectly cast
I think he's perfectly cast in
everything I've ever seen him in a huge
Philip Seymour Hoffman fan who is it
honestly let's just be honest with all
of ourselves but he was so good in this
I mean ah man everyone was so perfectly
cast even Terra Reeve was perfectly cast
which is a sentence I just didn't think
I was ever gonna say Tara Reid is
perfectly cast in this it's so mean
holy help carry I actually wrote Anna
holy hell Tana and then I realized her I
remembered
without fail in every single comment
section of any video I'm ever in someone
says good work Terra or I hate you Terra
or whatever something something Terra
but my name's plastered everywhere for
like videos I mean like it literally
Tamara's never seen I don't get but
Terra thing is that just like a nickname
do people genuinely think that's my name
so that's why that's how I got there
that's how I remember first of all dude
you don't have an X secondly this is a
show dog with papers I can't board it it
gets upset and her hair falls out yes so
bunny gets held up for ransom so we
think there's a lot of back-and-forth
with this and I just threw out who wants
to kidnap Terry which didn't that's so
mean but and then the next thing that I
wrote is this isn't a want it's a need I
need that purple bowling suit Amazon
wishlist yeah well like you know that's
just your opinion man then you get the
hand off scene where they're trying to
get bunny back Terry back and Walter
just screws everything up he makes
everything so much more difficult than
it has to be it's kind of like an
infinity war when star wars just ruins
everything and it would've been very
easy for you not to just ruin everything
but you did you did ruin everything I'm
calling Walter hello
welcome man Tamara it's the dude what I
don't know what's happening I just I
needed to take my anger out
anyway dude where's your car not often
that you get to do a dude where's my car
Joe holy hell Julianne Moore just called
sex a natural zesty enterprise I wish
people called me a nasty natural zesty
just a few updates he's wearing jelly
sandals in a cab amazing then you see
Sam Elliot for the first time and that
man is just an actual heavenly creature
I love the dream sequences - there's a
couple of them I really really love them
I love that he gets drugged back down to
earth the first one with a bowling ball
then the second one there's all these
like showgirls dancing with bowling
headdresses and then he's like under
their skirts looking up and it's just
some dream world and I love it
when I get something wrong in one of
these episodes the nihilist fight scene
at the end is hilarious because they
realize that the dude and his friends
don't even have the money and they never
did and and they realized that they're
kind of caught and they're like well
we'll just take whatever money you have
and they're like okay well we have like
$4 here you go and then they start
fighting because Walter doesn't want to
give his money away which he'll yeah go
good for you Walter
then that fight scene is amazing that
bowling ball to them to the gut yeah
that's what I'm not in a movie sure yes
good I didn't get as close with Donny as
I got I feel like with Walter and with
the dude though I enjoyed Donny I really
enjoyed what his character was but just
someone to shit on and that was fun they
get his cremated remains they put it in
a coffee tin and then they scatter in
the ocean and Walter gives this speech
at the ends about kind of what he loved
to do and
he was their friend and he said you know
he liked to serve all the way up to
Pismo and I loved that because I grew up
right next to Pismo Beach the dude
abides ending his grapes I love that
there's no resolution with the bowling
tournament that they've kind of like
been building up to and they talk about
bowling so much they're always in the
bowling alley something goes really
really wrong they go to the bowling
alley to Bowl it's just so good the new
Toonami episode just came out with
stalls are created you spent the last
hour and a half watching and it's not a
critical service you know so back to the
review is this a weekday what day is
this
it's so relatable yes you'll probably be
surprised by how badass John Goodman is
here yeah Christopher Russo yeah I am
I've always been a fan of John Goodman
but this just took that fandom to
another level it was such a different
role for him it's like out there man yes
John Bailey also you did great as Tom
but you don't have episode that I just
bought you'll love it but will think it
has no plot and Jeff Bridges is amazing
Jeff Bridges is amazing I did love it it
had such a plot it had such I feel like
it had such a plot right I'm just
comparing it to last week with it like
it basically did not in my eyes my dumb
dumb brain did not have a plot at all so
yeah Jeff Bridges has a beard in this
movie man I guess that means Tamra finds
him SuperDuper sexy but that is just
like her opinion dude
yeah it'll pretty much be like the last
one you'll have no idea what the hell
are you watching that is so weird there
are quite a few comments like that in
these predictions no cuz this like this
hadith though it was ever-changing and
you know you had to kind of be on your
toes it definitely had a plat and this I
felt like I could possibly be stoned but
still have an idea of what's going on in
my freakin life and fear loathing in las
vegas i felt like i was on acid and had
no idea what planet i was on or what
century i was in i was able to follow
this one i wasn't able to follow a
fearful thing and it wasn't very able to
follow this one it was so weird it's
probably my favorite comedy at the end
of the story i think friendship in its
many forms is what stands out the most
to me they're a bunch of losers way in
over their head but damn they are
endearing yes man that's totally what I
got from it too is the friendship that
they both have and all three of them had
but especially Walter and the dude have
this weird interest and very interesting
friendship that really comes out it's
like this super lovely thing even though
it's super messed up a lot of the times
and they both have some major issues
they need to work through but I don't
know yeah I got that too there will be
White Russians consumed Cheers I think
just having this prop was worth buying
the vodka and hula better I just don't
like vodka drinks that much so you can
have the rest
Rico I loved it I could see myself
easily watching this again and I'm
really excited to go to the tail awesome
studios next time we film and talk about
it with all them thank you so much for
watching I will see you all next week
at least I'm house-trained
look at that little sausage okay look at
how beautiful he is that's just a
stunning
[Music]
[Applause]
you